hallo herzliche braunen meine tochter
ich möchte mich in diesem videos erst
einmal dafür gewachsen das so zahlreiche
abonnenten und zuschauer sich beim einem
gewinnspiel beteiligt haben
das werde ich am morgen am ende und aus
losen ich bin selbst schon sehr gespannt
wer gewinnen wird
am liebsten würde ich alles geben also
alles gewinnt steht einfach so viel
anklang gefunden hast echt nie gedacht
dass so viele mitmachen
deswegen einmal herzlichen dank dafür
und in diesem video wollte mal auf eine
aktuelle frage eingehen
viele von euch haben das schon gesehen
dass ich mir eine kitchenette gekauft
habe endlich nach langem suchen habe ich
einen gefunden habe ich jetzt aufhören
ein zwei videos benutzt und ich möchte
ich jetzt einfach mal sagen wo ich sehr
besorgt habe weil es einfach viele
anfragen kamen wo ich sie gekauft habe
womöglich intrade am günstigsten findet
auf was man achten muss und zwar war es
so dass ich mich im internet natürlich
erkundigt habe wo ich eine kitchenette
günstigsten finde ich war bei ebay bei
amazon bei verschiedenen versandhäuser
otto schwab also der wirklich überall
nach der kitchenaid gesucht habe auch
bei qvc schon geschaut und es waren
alles so angebote um die 650 euro was
natürlich eine menge geld ist und im mai
war ich dann letztendlich auf dem
maimarkt bei uns in mannheim
und da war extra entstand für die
kitchenaid und zwar von der firma extra
cash aus mannheim im explizit als
leckerer die filiale und da gab es für
mich das beste angebot da hat nämlich
die kitchenaid mit dem ganzen zubehör
500 euro
euro gekostet ich zeige ich es einmal
das zubehör und zwar waren diese
küchenmaschine dabei mit einer schüssel
mit schlips und natürlich mit dem früher
wesen dieser und dem ihr das nimmt meyer
für klee steige das nimmt ma lin festere
teigige rührteig und schneebesen
gebracht für schnee oder für lockerere
massen zusammen wie zum beispiel dann
war doch da war eine zweite schüssel
eigentlich eine metallschüssel ich hab
sie dann ausgetauscht in der
glasschüssel das war für mich besser
weil ich so reichen den videos besser
zeigen kann wie sich die sachen in der
schüssel vermischen
bei der glasschüssel weiß noch den
deckel 3 dann hier dieser fleischwolf
bis zwei aufsätzen war einmal der
feineren einmal der größere aufsatz und
stadtbahnhof dabei hier diese gemüse
schneider
da habe ich jetzt den aufsatz drin mit
dem man scheiben schneiden kann so
gurkenscheiben zum beispiel weiß nicht
ob man das so sehen
und natürlich die gemüsereste einmal in
fein und einfach grob und dieses angebot
wie gesagt liegt bei 599 euro
und wie gesagt gab es dieses angebot für
599 euro eben nur auf reimer und zwar
einfach so maimarkt special
ich habe mich dann gefragt oder viele
andere haben wir dann auch links
geschickt so internet seiten wo ist die
kitchenaid für 300 euro gab
dann habe ich aber genauer nachgeschaut
es geht einfach zwei arten von der
kitchen aid oder sogar drei und die
günstigere ist eben die kitchenaid
klassik das ist eine kleinere
küchenmaschine damit ihr nach augen
angeschaut ich meinen keller drei läufen
sparen können habe mich dagegen
entschieden weil die einfach nicht so
viel zugehört und ich denke wenn man
sich die küchenmaschine schon kauf
sollte man sich diese arten kaufen
die gibt es nämlich auch in tausend
farben
ich glaube in deutschland um die 25 30
in amerika fast 60 farben und ihr habt
einfach die freie auswahl bei dieser
firma jetzt im internet ist es nämlich
oft so dass in vier farben bekommt
schwarz weiß rot und silber oder eben
und beide firma experte schätzt kann man
sich alle frank bestellen die welt lange
nämlich direkt von kitchenaid dahin
geliefert und das angebot gab sind nicht
wirklich nicht mehr
und zwar ist gestern nochmal in mannheim
neckarau weil ich mir noch ein super
herr für die kids schnell kaufen wollte
beziehungsweise ich wollte mir den
toaster angucken lebens auch gibt und
hab ins gespräch gekommen wie dem herrn
kinder
er hat mir auch bei auf dem maimarkt
diese maschine verkauft und ich habe
einfach mal gefragt ob es vielleicht die
möglichkeit geben dieses maimarkt
angebot noch mal zu machen explizit für
meine abonnenten und jetzt haben wir
eben auf gemacht und er hat es bestätigt
und gesagt dass es dieses angebot eben
nochmal gibt für meine art um händen
das heißt ihr könnt mir jetzt eine e
mail schreiben und sagen ihnen welche ob
energie steht haben wollte und ich leite
das e mail weiter unterhalt schilder
oder sein kollege wird sich dann bei
euch melden
und ich hab mir jetzt noch überlegt so
als kleines dankeschön würde ich von mir
noch eine schürze mit reinlegen
ihr kennt ja meine küchenschürze ich mir
gedrückt habe diese mit dem logo
trauungsort und ich wünsche euch dann
noch eure namen darauf drucken
das wäre doch so das angebot so ist
dankeschön was ihr von mir bekommen
würde
und der vorteil eben wenn ihr jetzt die
kitchenaid in mannheim lecker aufkaufen
würde eben über diese extra resch firma
dann würdet ihr es ja auch kostenlos
nach hause geliefert bekommen und ihr
habt natürlich eine garantie falls es
irgendwie normal was wäre was ich
natürlich nicht glaube und ich hoffe
dann habt ihr immer noch
darum kümmerte das ist also nicht so wie
in der internetversand ich habe mich
gegen den internetversand entschieden
wir hatten auch mal den fernseher und
eingekauft uns zum beispiel den
kinderwagen von meiner tochter
das war einfach irgendwann so dass der
fernseher kaputt war ich hatte keinen
ansprechpartner und keiner wird sich
kümmern die firma gab es plötzlich nicht
mehr deswegen saß mehreren summe auf
unsere kosten beim kinderwagen genau das
gleiche der kinder war kaputt ich wollte
einen reklamieren und ein ersatzteil und
habe das auch nie bekommen
deswegen sage ich mir jetzt immer so
große sachen würde ich nie mehr im
internet bestellen lieber zahle ich
etwas mehr und habt einen
ansprechpartner
aber in dem fall saliera nicht mehr also
dieses angebot wirklich günstiger als im
internet überhaupt außer ihr würdet die
kitchenaid gebrauch bei ebay oder
irgendwo kaufen aber hab da eben wie
gesagt auch keine garantie und bei ebay
shops problem dass viele aus dem ausland
geliefert wird aus österreich ausreisen
oder italien unter habt einfach gar
keine gewährleistung falls das spiel
dann habt ihr in der defekte maschine
und keiner kann sich darum kümmern wie
gesagt dass ich alles zubehör ihr könnt
euch natürlich auch extras zu stellen
die firma hat alle anderen kitchenaid
produkte wie waffeleisen was ganzen
darauf fußte forscher
und ja diese starke mixas oder als
wirklich alles und auch der kirchenseite
könnt ihr euch zum beispiel die ganzen
farben anschauen
meine farbe ist jetzt die hindernisse
schon knalliges pink in metalloptik aber
wie gesagt das tägliche arbeiten
und ja wenn ihr euch dafür interessiert
und einen kitchenaid kaufen wollt dann
schreibt mir eine e mail an sales
trocken
erst mail.com ich schreibe euch meine
internet adresse e mail adresse nochmal
unten in dieser infobox rein da könnt
ihr direkt eine email schreiben und ich
leite dann einfach an kinder weiter geht
zum schluss gleich noch eine frage und
zwar werde ich oft gefragt zertifikat
nicht abonnent werden von deiner seite
ich weiß nicht es geht das ist ganz
einfach
ihr legt euch ein publikum dazu man
kostenlos ist also e mail konto und
könnt euch dann mit diesem bei youtube
anmelden dass ich auch kostenlos ihr
habt dann praktisch euren eigenen kanal
das ist vergleichbar mit eurer facebook
seite also euer profil euren kanal und
könnten andere kanäle abonnieren also
praktisch wie bei facebook diese gefällt
mir markierung dann seht ihr immer
irgendwer die neuesten beiträge hardware
neue videos hat wenn ich vielleicht was
anderes kommentiert bei dem video dann
könnt ihr das auch verfolgen was ich da
so schreibt und mit ihr kommt auch eine
e mail wenn ihr wollt nach nach hause
bundestag eine e mail auf eur in ihr
postfach
das eben jetzt ein video online ist das
ganze ist kostenlos wenn das abo auch
kündigungen euch kanäle nicht gefallen
und habe soeben die möglichkeit eure
youtube startseite sowie den
einzurichten und das zu sehen was ich
eben interessiert und ich kann so eben
auch sehen wer an einem kanal
interessiert ist und wie viele zuschauer
ich habe wie viele verfolger ich habe
und bekommt so eben auch zurück
die videos könnt ihr natürlich auch
immer positiv oder negativ bewerten
ich find's ganz schön wenn ihr mir eine
negativ bewertung geben warnt dass er
eben auch dazu schreibt was ihr jetzt
nicht so schön fand eigentlich leute die
dann ganz gerne negativ bewertung
abgeben aber nicht sagen willi so und
ich würde gern wissen wie es so wie ihr
jetzt negativ bewertungen abgibt was ich
verbessern könnte vielleicht gefällt
euch den kanal an sich nicht oder das
rezept nicht oder irgendwie
kameraeinstellungen und wenn es eben
sachen sind die ich ändern kann dann
würde ich es auch gerne machen
um eben mich auch weiter zu entrichten
und wer ihr wollt kann ich euch jetzt
auch immer mehr meinen werkzeuge mein
material zeigen ich wende mich oft
gefragt wo ich die sachen her habe ich
kann mich auch mal zeigen was so die
vorteile verzichten rät sind ich war ja
ursprünglich nur von der optik angetan
aber mittlerweile weiß die
küchenmaschine richtig gut ist ich habe
viel bessere im bild die besseren
rührteig also da ist schon richtig power
dahinter
und ich kann mich das auch mal mit
meiner anderen küchenmaschine
vergleichen und dann können wir selbst
abwägen ob wir sehen was für euch ist
oder nicht ich kann es auf jeden fall
empfehlen wird sie auch nicht mehr
hergeben
und ich denke video mal zu meinem genug
falls ihr interesse habt schreibt mir
wie gesagt eine e-mail und ich würde
mich freuen von euch zu hören
jetzt kann er noch fleißig bei den
gewinnspielen mitmachen das geht bis
morgen abend 20 uhr
danach werde ich wie gesagt aus losen
netzwerk filmen und dann bekomme neben
vier leute ihre gewinne und jetzt würde
ich euch noch einen schönen tag und wir
sehen uns als ihr angetan